Hello everybody!
Did you fucking know if you don't play- if you don't touch the game, fucking Arlo the horse takes over as the main character?
Like what the fuck?
I like booted up my game and I was like, oh hey there's me sleeping.
And then suddenly the camera locks into fucking Arlo.
I was like, what's he doing?
And then he walks away.
I was like, what the fuck?
What the fuck is going on?
So I was just like watching the horse.
I was literally just like watching the horse just fucking walking away from my body.
And he just runs around.
And I was just like, where is he going?
Where the fuck is this horse going?
I was like, I thought I was the main character.
What the fuck is going on?
So like while I was just waiting for him to come back.
I was just trying to fix the stream.
Because you know, I actually almost started with a 10 minute delay.
Because I was like, why is the start stream not going out?
I was like, why isn't the starting screen not fucking- why is it not letting me start the stream?
And I was like, oh the 10 minute delay.
So yeah, we're just gonna- Look see I'm the last- It's so weird.
I'm also on the left side of the screen.
I know.
I know it's like really rare to see me on the left side of the screen.
But I've had people on the last Shadow Colossus being like, I need to see the stamina bar.
Where's the stamina bar, Dokie?
Where the fuck is the stamina bar?
So then like, you know, I decided to be like, you know what?
I'll be nice today.
Today, I feel nice today.
Okay, don't say I don't do nothing for you guys.
Okay, guys, don't say I don't do anything for you guys.
Because I, um, I worked so hard to be on the left screen.
Just so you guys know, I worked so fucking hard.
It took so much courage and determination to like break out of routine and like be on the left side.
So if you say I don't do anything for you guys, that's a fucking lie.
Because now I'm on the left side of the screen.
Oh shit, what happened to Arlo?
Oh, it's night time?
Okay.
I guess, I guess now that it's night time, they're like, Arlo is like, never mind.
But yes, anyway, a little update.
I know it's like, it seems out of nowhere.
But I now have my creep- Okay, well I always had my creator code.
But just so you guys know, this creator code is actually the old creator code.
But I name changed it to Doki Bird.
So like now, the old creator code doesn't work anymore.
So you have to use Doki Bird.
And I wanna say like a huge shout out to Fortnite.
Because like they actually like, uh, was like, was a real- I was talking to a real person by the way.
Like I- I actually got fired.
I had to talk to a real person.
And they like helped me.
They were like, oh, we're gonna have to figure this out today.
Like slash tomorrow.
Like, you know, tomorrow.
Because I contacted them on Sunday.
And it's like, it was like, I don't know, 6pm on a Sunday.
And then they're like, um, okay.
So they're like, okay, we're gonna like try and see if we could like get it fixed tomorrow.
When like the staff is there.
And then I was like, okay.
And then I received a message.
And they're like, oh, we actually can help you with it right now.
And then we had to like grab some stuff.
Grab some information.
Um...
And then like, uh...
And then they managed to actually- At first I was just like, oh, I just want to like, you know, just get my skins.
I don't care.
I don't care about losing everything else.
Please just give me my skins.
I was like, please.
I don't care about my Fortnite skins.
Bro, please.
I retail therapy'd so hard on Fortnite.
Because Fortnite skins was the only thing that made me happy back then.
And I bought a John Cena Fortnite skin.
And then I bought like basketball.
Dragon Ball Z Cell skin.
Please.
I bought so many dance emotes.
And then- And then they were like, oh, you know what?
We can get you your entire Epic account back.
We'll like help you change the email.
I was like, oh, thank God.
I was like- I was just like, oh, thank God.
I- You know what?
I- I came in here with super low expectations.
Because I thought I was not even able to get back my account.
Because everybody would tell me it was so hard.
To get back your account.
And that like, I just have to be ready for them to say no.
Because like my manager couldn't like get in touch with anybody for two months.
I even asked the Twitch staff.
Because they've done Twitch Rivals with Fortnite.
And they were like, oh, just so you know.
Go in with super low expectations, man.
I don't know.
Because I was like, can you reach out to Fortnite for me?
And Fortnite staff had asked them if they could get me my account back.
And even Twitch staff was like, oh, you have to go in with super low expectations.
And then- And then I put in my last ditch effort.
Public pressure.
Because- Because if it can work out for YouTube, maybe it can work on Fortnite.
If nothing else works, public pressure is my last ditch effort.
I- I'm not- I'm not a Fortnite fan.
I'm not ashamed.
I'm not- I'm- I'm not ashamed.
I- I was desperate, guys.
So thank you, everybody, for signal boosting.
I was so fucking desperate.
I really- I really wanted my account back.
So thank you guys for- For helping out and helping me signal boost.
So that Fortnite saw the tweet.
And they like personally DM'd me.
And was like, hey, we can help you out.
And I was like, oh my God, a real person.
I was like- I was like, oh my God, a real person wants to help me out.
I was so- Bro, even- Even Twitch was like, bro, I don't know, man.
Even Twitch was like, I don't- This is what happened!
Arlo's going on his own adventure again.
Because at first I was like, there's me.
I was like, wait, why is the camera moving away from me?
What is going on?
What the fuck is- Why is the camera moving away?
That's not me!
And then he fucking just starts running around the map.
The real- The real main character.
But yeah, that is the story of how I- I got my Fortnite account back.
So for those who were like- For those who were like, what does the creator code do?
Basically, it's basically like when you go to the shop, there's like support a creator and you just copy and paste on Fortnite.
And then you just paste Doki Bird.
And basically it's like every purchase you make in the shop, whether you're buying V-Bucks or whether you're buying any item in the shop, I get like- I don't remember what the percent was.
I think it was like 5% or was it?
It was like 5%.
I remember like back then, I made a joke be- I was- people were like saying, no Doki, you have a problem with Fortnite skins.
But like the first month of Fortnite, the first month my creator- creator code came out, I got $2,500.
And that was 5% of whatever the fuck you guys were purchasing.
So like in the end, I don't have a problem.
If I get 5% and I end up getting $2,500 in the first month from people using my creator code, I'm not the one with the problem.
So we all- we all as a group have issues.
All of us have issues.
It's not just me.
Because I got 5% and that 5% was $2,500.
So somebody- some of you dragons have more of a problem than me.
Someone calculate how many V-Bucks- how many dollars worth of V-Bucks was that?
Something-
So you guys- you guys can't judge me on my specs.
I have spending issues.
What the hell?
Yeah.
You guys can't judge me anymore when it comes to my spending.
Anyway, I'm glad there's no 10 minute delay.
Because I accidentally almost spent- have a- have like 10 minute delay there.
Alright.
Today, we're gonna re- oh I also forgot how to play this game cause like...
Uh...
I forgot how to play this game cause it's been a while.
We were able to play it last week so you guys are gonna help me with remembering this.
Alright Arlo, this is my time.
You're not the main character anymore.
Continue.
Oh I got to defeat five colossi.
Wait, colossi- oh yeah!
Colossi is the plural of Colossus.
Whoops.
Alright.
I'll play this game again.
It's not an issue.
I can stop whenever I want.
Aphelia, thank you for the- for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay.
This is the hitting button.
Okay and then- why is my camera so wonky right now?
Alright.
Okay.
And then...
That's Arlo.
Alright, where is it?
Where is it?
This way?
Alright, we have to go this way.
Alright, Arlo.
It's back to figuring how to control this camera.
Alright, five down.
Okay, wait.
Where is it?
This way.
Alright, here we go.
How do I- how do I- wait, I can stand up?
Wait, why would I need to stand up?
How did I do that?
How did I- how did I do that?
What- what?
Stand back up!
Okay, now I can stand on- why would I need to stand on the horse?
I don't understand- to jump?
Oh!
Oh, that is not gonna be fun.
Okay.
That is- that is not gonna be fun when I actually have to do that.
Okay, how do I ride this horse?
Okay.
Alright.
How do I- guys, I'm trying to remember how to ride this horse.
Okay, triangle.
Alright, it's triangle.
Okay.
Okay, where do I have to go?
Oh, God.
I remember now why I hated this.
I hated the horse riding mechanic.
I remember now.
I remember now why I hated it.
Chat.
Alright, let's try and remember- alright.
How many?
Eleven, right?
We have eleven to go?
Alright.
Don't worry.
This is gaming hours.
Right here.
The moment- look.
Even though- even though, like, um, I'm very forgetful and that, like, uh, and, like, it takes me a while to figure out the mechanics, but the moment I figure it out, I go- I go- I'm full gamer.
You can't deny that, chat.
The moment I figure out the mechanics, even though, like, you know, I'm a little slow at figuring stuff out.
I start gaming, okay?
Okay, guys.
Just so you remember.
I start gaming the moment I realize what the mechanics are.
Alright, do I have to go up?
The fuck is it?
It's, like, here.
What's the map?
Alright.
Okay.
And is it, like- do I get to climb this?
Let's see.
Or do I go around it?
Do I go around this?
Maybe?
Is there an around?
Or maybe I can climb.
You know what?
Maybe I can climb this.
Okay.
Wait.
Does the fruit do anything?
There's fruit here?
Can I eat that?
Can I eat the fruit?
Alright, let's see.
How do I- Okay.
I'm crouching.
Alright.
Let's see if I can eat the fruit.
Oh, I can eat the fruit!
Can I?
Guys.
I don't know if I pick up?
Pick up the fruit?
Oh!
Okay.
Wait.
How do I eat it?
Eat the fruit.
Eat the fruit!
Guys, I eat the fruit.
I'm so screwed.
Guys, I figured it out.
It was hard to see.
I told you guys!
The moment I figured out the mechanics, I started gaming.
Oh wait, there's more.
I told you guys.
Camera, please.
The moment I figured this out, I started gaming.
Okay, this is not fair.
I actually have to...
This is not fair because I literally can't see it on the camera.
But look at that gaming.
This is called FPS.
Pure FPS skills right there.
Prediction time!
Actual gaming right there.
Alright, not to remember how to climb.
Okay.
I can't climb this, guys.
Apparently I can't climb this.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta figure out how to get to the other colossi.
Sorry.
Pure TPS right there.
Alright, now we have more HP.
I feel like maybe we can go around from here?
Right?
Oh no.
I wish there was a lost emote.
Maybe here?
It has to be here.
Is that an indent in the wall?
No, it's just a wall.
It's just a fucking wall.
Oh no.
This is the worst part.
It's the other way!
Okay, I'm going back.
Alright, we're figuring this out.
Guys, we're gonna figure this out.
Go Arlo, go.
Hey, like, at least I'm eating and drinking water.
Right?
My guy is actually eating and drinking water.
So like, you know, things are not bad.
You know?
He's staying hydrated and like...
surviving.
Okay.
This way.
Go Arlo, go.
Please.
It's really hard to open a...
an acupuncture massage parlor in this neighborhood.
We get like one client every like couple of months.
Don't worry.
My dead girlfriend will appreciate this for sure.
Do I go up?
Let's see.
Oh, no.
That's not the sword.
I wish I had a magical bow.
It sucks.
Why did the...
Why did the devil only bless my fucking sword and not my bow?
Like, if they can bless more than one thing... Like, if they can bless one thing, they might as well bless the other.
You know?
You need magical arrows?
I'll just come and pick it up.
It's not like I shot it pretty far.
If it's magical, it'll be glowing.
Please, Arlo!
Just walk around the trees.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, this is... Oh, no.
I don't like this.
Where am I?
Magic sword!
Okay, this way.
Alright.
There.
Look.
They can bless, like... Please.
Okay, I'm getting off.
I'm getting off!
Arlo's pissing me off.
I'm not lost yet!
I have the sun!
I have the power of the sun!
Wait, maybe it's down here?
It has to be, right?
Like, why would there be a cave?
Okay.
Nice.
Boon the Nomad.
What?
Where?
There's a person here?
I got an achievement.
Can I steal your stuff?
What?
Oh, is this an Easter egg?
I can't steal anything?
Why can't I steal anything?
I'm having an Easter egg if I can't steal...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
What the fuck did I pick up?
That's it?
What's that?
What the fuck did I pick up?
What do I do with that?
It just exists?
It just...
What was that?
Okay.
Oh well.
It just exists in my pocket now.
I don't know what I received, but it just exists on me for some reason.
Alright.
Time to figure out where to go.
Sword.
Oh no.
Where the fuck's the sun?
All the trees are blocking the sun.
This way.
Okay.
It's this way.
Do I just jump down?
Is this it?
Oh, this is it.
That'll be fine.
Watch this.
Watch this, guys.
I don't know why he's hesitating.
I have a feeling I shouldn't jump down.
Do you guys think I can catch one of the rocks down there?
I think so.
Okay.
Actually, guys, I'm not gonna do it.
Because I need to find a shrine first.
I don't want to...
I don't want to shoot the things again.
Man, I wonder why the main character was hesitating just now.
I wonder why.
I think that's the road down, right?
This has to be the road down.
Okay.
Pew.
Oh, where's the sun?
Oh, this fucking tiny piece of shade blocked it?
Has to be here.
How do I get down from there?
Okay, I'm just...
That shouldn't kill me, right?
I don't know.
I like how the main character was like, No.
The main character was like, Please.
Please, Doki.
Don't do it.
I don't know.
Surely that will...
Arna, why are you running ahead?
Arna.
Look, I'm trying to...
I'm testing the limits.
I'm trying to like test the limits of like fall damage.
Okay.
Oh my god.
The horse riding mechanic has to be like the hardest mechanic.
Wait, what's this over there?
What's that over there?
There's like a little hole.
What is that?
Is that the way down?
Oh, it was.
I missed the hole.
Whoops.
Did I?
Did I miss the hole?
Oh my god.
Where...
This is just a tiny shade.
What do you mean?
I can't fucking see anything.
Alright, this has to be the place.
This has to be the area.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is the shade?
Where's the sun?
Oh my god.
Oh, the clouds are blocking the sun.
How am I gonna find out where to go?
Is this the area?
Was it here?
Was I looking at here?
Oh, it's this way.
Wait, is this not the area?
Oh my god.
I'm just...
What?
Did I like activate something?
I can't...
The game was like, no.
I can't even jump over here.
It was like, no.
No cheesing.
I like how the game was like, no, no, no, donkey, no cheesing this.
I am looking at the map.
What do you mean?
I'm looking at it right now.
It's so hard to be a traveling acupuncture specialist.
It really is.
I need to like stop allowing like, home visits.
I guess there's...
I really need to like stop allowing home visits for like acupuncture massages.
I really need to stop that.
Oh wait, is this sand?
Is it a sand...
a sand colossal?
Where is it?
Okay, it's this way?
Alright.
I don't know.
I don't trust like...
I feel like when you're like a specialist that just travels to like... travels to people's homes for your thing.
It's so risky.
What if you get murdered?
Like that sounds so fucking risky.
You don't know where they come from.
You know where they come from.
I love sand.
I hate sand.
This has to be it.
Is this it?
That's just a...
That's just a rock.
Where the fuck does this guy live?
Where the fuck do you live?
Sir?
Here?
Underground?
Where the fuck is here?
Oh, oh.
Here, here, here.
Okay.
Get off.
Alright.
Here you go.
He has to live here.
There's no other way.
It has to be here.
Alright.
I figured it out.
He's underneath.
He's underground.
Climb.
Wait.
Crouch?
I know you can crouch.
Oh, that's all?
Okay, never mind.
Apparently, I don't know how to crouch.
I was wrong.
He definitely did not know how to crouch.
Weeeee.
Alright.
Time to go to my next appointment.
Hello, sir.
Your acupuncture specialist is here.
Don't worry.
My rates are very reasonable.
I'll be five out of five stars on Yelp.
I would die if I...
Oh my God.
No!
Why didn't they stop me?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
We're gonna...
Oh, my God.
Oh, whoa.
Yay.
I'm so sorry.
I actually thought I was gonna die.
I legitimately thought I was gonna die.
Thank God.
Thank God, Woz.
But Woz saved my life.
Alright, what do you look like?
Don't worry, sir.
Where does it...
Where is all your stress?
Oh my God.
He big.
Is that a gorilla?
With a beard?
Is it monkey?
Oh, it's a brother?
Your brother's not...
Your brother is so fucking alive, sir.
Okay.
Where do I...
Oh.
Do I go here?
Where are these...
Where are these fucking...
Woz?
Oh, yep.
Alright.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my God.
How did you walk that fast?
You were so bow.
What?
You just jumped like 2 miles away from me.
How does that...
How did I get hurt?
Like, what?
Alright, here I go.
Here I go.
I don't know how he's suddenly so fucking fast, but here I go.
Weeeeee!
Okay.
Okay, now I don't know.
Now I don't know.
What do I do?
I'm like a little rat.
Hello, sir.
Hello.
Please.
Your brother really liked it.
He's totally very much alive.
He just didn't call you because he's just so fucking relaxed.
Okay?
He just didn't call you because he was just so relaxed, sir!
What's he gonna do?
Hit me?
He doesn't know what to do.
He's just looking at me.
What's he gonna do?
He's just walking around.
Hello.
Yay!
I don't know.
Is he gonna come closer?
Hello?
We'll grab your beard!
Ah!
Sir, you need to trim your fucking beard, sir.
I actually have no idea where the weak point is.
I did not pay...
Oh, it's on the head!
It's always on the head!
Because you're always stressed in the head.
Don't worry!
I'm here!
Oh, god.
The specialist is here.
I need a re- Oh, oh.
My god.
Please do not resist!
Do not resist, sir!
It is for...
Do you wanna live long?
If you wanna live long and prosper, you gotta take this!
Boom!
There you go.
I really... I need to like chill a little bit.
No, wait.
That's just the oil!
It's called stress oil!
Trust the process!
It's not blood!
It might look like blood!
But it's just all the excess oil in your head!
Because you're thinking too much, sir!
You are just thinking too much!
Alright, there you go.
I need to figure out where the other one is.
I'm going to go to the...
Okay, I need to figure out where the other one is.
Don't worry, I'm a fucking licensed professional.
I got my license online.
That's when you know I'm professional.
I'm going to assume it's the back.
I'm going to assume.
Like all toxic.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Please.
Okay, I'm going to assume it's back here.
Oh, my God.
I fucking knew it.
Only a professional would know this.
Don't worry.
A licensed professional knows where all the toxic is.
Oh, no.
Fuck.
Okay.
This is going to be bad.
Please stop shaking, sir.
Please stop shaking.
You have like... I can feel the toxic energy right here.
You have really bad back acne, sir.
Don't worry.
I think the hardest part was literally trying to find your house, sir.
Like you need a better address, man.
Like you need a mailbox outside.
How would people deliver your mail?
Please!
Look at all these stress juice!
There you go.
We did it.
Look at all that oil coming out of his body.
He sure used it.
Let the impurities... Yes!
It's the black acne!
Okay, I don't know if it's like an Asian parents thing.
But like I know... Oh god.
Sorry, the black ac... No!
The black acne on my... It's got me.
So like...
I don't know if this is an Asian parents thing or just a regular parents thing.
But like...
When you're growing up, your mom would...
My mom would always like talk about the...
What is it called?
The like...
The black oil on your nose and stuff.
And like...
Like she would like try to squeeze the...
She would like...
Be like, no you have...
There's so much black oil on your nose!
She always gives me like these things to put...
Yeah, the blackhead.
Yeah!
My mom would always talk about the blackheads and stuff on my nose.
And like...
Like when I get them.
She's like, no you have to fucking...
Squeeze it.
I'm like, okay, I don't think...
I don't think squeezing is the right thing to do.
It's actually bad.
Yeah.
I was like...
And then later on...
In life I was like...
Oh my god, wait you be squeezing...
Squeezing is actually really bad for your fucking skin?
Who would've thought?
I did it.
Another happy customer.
Yeah, you need like a fucking...
Those like...
Fucking tape stuff for your nose.
You get like blackheads.
Don't worry.
I'm here to squeeze the giant's nose...
For their blackhead treatment.
Alright.
Yeah, you can leave scars.
Yeah.
I wish little Doki knew about...
No, I don't have scars on my nose by the way.
I don't have scars on my nose.
But it definitely did not help my skin.
Definitely.
It definitely did not help my skin.
By squeezing the black...
The blackheads out.
Alright.
It's time to save.
Pray to save.
Yay!
Another happy customer.
Pray to save.
Pray.
Nice.
Right.
Where's the other one?
Okay.
Oh my god, is it the sand time?
No it's not sand time, cause it's in the opposite direction.
Nevermind.
Alright.
It's not sand time because it's in the opposite direction.
Alright, here we go.
I also don't know how to fucking turn on this horse.
It's lake time?
I thought it was sand time.
You guys were like the sand snake.
Okay, this way.
I just have to go straight.
Straight time.
Yeah!
Alright, here we go.
It's this way.
Is this the lake?
Oh my god, do you remember the lake?
Hey Arlo, do you remember?
Do you remember the happy times we had in that?
Alright, we have to figure out how to get down.
I actually don't remember how to get down from the lake.
How do I get down from here?
How the fuck?
Where the fuck is the ladder?
Where is the ladder?
Is it through this bridge?
Just jump.
Guys, no.
I know we can't just jump.
We've tested that theory before.
Is that bridge?
Is that a bridge?
No, that's not a bridge.
I can't tell.
It's just fucking there.
Oh, it's the wrong way?
Okay.
God, I'm so directionless.
Oh my god.
Thank god I was born in a time when GPS exists.
Like, thank god.
Please, Arlo!
Turn around!
There you go.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'm happy.
I know people are like, would you rather be born like 50 years ago or like in the past or 50 years in the future?
I think I like where I'm currently at.
Maybe like a little bit.
Maybe I wish I was born like a little bit.
Um...
Did I just go back the same way?
No.
No?
Oh, fuck it.
We'll figure it out later.
I don't think I did, right?
I don't know if... did I just went back the same way?
I can't tell.
I can't.
It's under.
It's like the lake is below me.
I know the lake is... this is the lake.
Yeah.
This is the lake.
Is this a lake or is this an ocean?
I'll never know.
This has to be the lake.
Okay.
I do sometimes wish... wait, no.
Wait, is this a lake or an ocean?
This is an ocean.
There's a lake?
It's all...
It's all water!
Yeah!
How am I supposed to tell?
They're all the same!
It's just water.
Oh my god.
I have... I don't think I'm meant to ride horses.
Please.
Yeah, I'm definitely not meant to ride horses.
But you know how people... Okay, this is not the right way.
People are like, oh, would you rather be born 50 years ahead?
I wish I was born maybe like... maybe like 10 years... maybe like 5 years in advance.
Because like I was... so then I can like be more of a... I can be like full-on zoomer.
But with like... but with like... with like more FPS skills.
Sorry.
I could grow up longer playing video games.
Please.
Is this a lake?
The sword keeps pointing down.
How the fuck do I go down?
Is that a lake?
Or is... or is it the lake behind me?
No, I... because I've been there.
That's where I killed the other Colossus.
Okay.
Lake.
Follow the path?
The path says down!
But then I've already been to that Colossus!
Where the fuck's the lake?
Because like I was there already!
Alright, I guess we'll do this again?
I hate going over here because there's no fucking light.
There's like no light at all here.
So I just have to rely on like pure instinct and I don't have that.
Also, I don't want to be born like... like back.
I'd rather be born ahead but not too ahead because I'm scared of global war.
What?
Not too ahead because I think we sort of fucked up the planet.
I'm not sure yet though.
And I don't want to... I don't want to be born too ahead to find out.
What?
I don't want to like find out.
I think we sort of... I don't know.
I don't know.
Judging by what the weather's like currently... I don't know.
Also, if I was born too far back in the past...
There's no... there's no internet.
And I don't know how to survive...
Well, to be fair, if I didn't grow up with the internet...
I wouldn't have to worry about like not knowing how to survive without it.
But like... oh my god.
I'd have to get a...
If it weren't for the internet...
I'd have to get a real job.
Where are you going?
Try to fucking figure out if this is the lake.
Is this the lake?
Are you a lake, sir?
There's no way because I killed a colossi up here.
Where the fuck... where's the lake?
There's so many bodies of water!
Is this lake?
We're muster.
Muster where?
Keep going?
Okay, I'll go this way.
Arlo, get over here.
Arlo!
Should I go this way?
It's further north.
I don't know.
Am I going north?
Guys, there's no compass.
Am I...
Oh my god.
Where's my phone app to tell me where I am?
Where's my... bro, I'll even take Apple Maps at this point.
That's how desperate I am.
I'm so desperate I'll even use... I'll even use Apple Maps.
You have a map?
Does this map look fucking...
Does this map look like it's readable?
It doesn't tell me where lake is.
There's no...
My GPS doesn't even work!
This is a shitty GPS because I require the fucking sun!
It's a solar powered sword!
It's literally a solar powered sword.
I don't know what to tell you.
Okay.
Alright, solar powered sword.
My power.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Lake?
Are you a lake?
Okay, wait.
There's a sun over here.
Oh my god.
There's a sun.
Okay.
Lake time.
Okay, sword.
Tell me where to go.
This way.
Okay, this way.
Alright, I figured it out!
My sword!
My solar powered GPS tells me to go this way!
Oh my god, the reception here is fucking terrible.
Everything I do for my dead girlfriend.
Okay, there better be like...
Okay, she better not fucking cheat on me after saving her fucking life.
I swear to god.
I swear to fucking god.
If she leaves me...
If she fucking leaves me after I killed 15 colossi for her...
I swear to fucking god.
I'm going through so much just to fucking save her life.
Okay.
No, no GPS.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
There is no water anywhere.
Where am I?
Oh god, I'm so lost.
What the fuck is this?
I don't know, do you know where lake is?
No?
Not... maybe this way?
This way seems like a lakey area.
This... is this... is this a... is this...
Is this a lakey area?
Bro, I'm desperate.
I'm using my legs.
This is how desperate I am.
I'm actually using my fucking legs.
Oh my god, someone give me the fucking sun.
Lake...
Lake, where are you?
Where's water?
Why is there so many lakes here?
We gotta industrialize this area.
We gotta make this a city so I don't have to deal with all these lakes.
Is that shrine?
No, those are just ruins.
Just rocks.
Where's the sun?
Where the fuck's the sun?
I think I'm going the right area?
Alright, I'm gonna trust you on this, boy.
I'm gonna trust you.
I'm gonna follow my heart.
My heart tells me that this is where the lake is.
If there's no lake here, I'm gonna make my own fucking lake.
Is this another area?
What the fuck?
Alright.
Me down this path.
There's a lake.
Maybe down this path, there's the lake I'm looking for.
And then...
Or the sun, you know.
I'll take either.
I'll take the fucking GPS.
My solar powered GPS.
Wait, wait, wait!
Oh my god.
Solar powered GPS.
Poodoo!
But...
Guys...
How the fuck do I get over there?
Did I go the wrong way?
Did I...
No, I must not have.
No, this has to be the right way!
There's no...
How do I get over to the other side?
There's no way.
No...
This has to be.
There's no other path.
That's literally the only path I have.
It's heading...
Wait.
It's heading further and further away from where my sword was gonna ask me to go.
But like...
It has to be.
It has to like miraculously turn right.
Like...
Please.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
Please.
It hasn't miraculously turned right.
Oh no.
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Riding a horse don't turn the six...
He travels automatic through these paths.
Oh he does?
Wait.
Does he?
Oh my god!
He moves on his own!
Oh my god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Everything changed.
This entire game changed for me.
I literally don't have to move.
He can move for me.
Guys, I think I went the wrong way guys.
Yeah, I'm...
I'm pretty sure I went the wrong way.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm heading to a new area.
I'm going to a new path.
I'm going to a new area.
Oh wait, I'm going up.
This might be where the lake is.
Oh my god.
Arlo knows where to go.
Okay, GPS.
Where do I go, GPS?
Where do I fucking go?
Did I go the wrong way?
Do I...
Is it like maybe...
Okay, guys, guys.
I'm going to go forward.
Maybe...
Maybe the lake is a sky lake.
Guys, maybe...
Guys, which way...
Which way?
Right or left?
Guys, right or left?
Guys...
This is left and this is right.
Left?
Okay.
Guys, maybe it's a sky lake.
Guys, maybe...
Maybe...
Maybe the lake is in the sky.
You don't know that.
Alright.
This has to be the lake.
There's no other explanation.
This has to be where the lake is.
Right?
There's no way.
Arlo knows.
Arlo, you know, right?
I trust in him.
I trust in this GPS powers.
Okay, let's just...
You...
Guys...
Bruh...
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, I don't think I'm at the right path.
For some reason...
I have a feeling I'm definitely...
I'm definitely not going the right way.
I don't know.
Oh, wait!
Unless...
Wait!
Arlo!
Oh my god!
Unless this is a lake!
I think I've...
Guys, I knew it!
You have to go up...
to go down!
This is it!
I fucking... Oh, I got a shrine too.
This is it.
I found the... I found the shrine.
This is almost like a lake.
Okay, have I been here?
Have I been to the shrine before?
No, because this is the first time prayed.
No, wait.
Wait, no.
I've been to the shrine before.
Wait.
No, this is the one of the two shrines...
I've been to.
Oh my god!
I've been here before!
Guys, I've been to the shrine before.
Alright.
Okay.
It's okay.
This has to be where the lake is now.
Alright, the lake...
The lake is this way.
This has to be the lake.
There's no...
How do I get over this?
It has to be over this platform.
Alright.
Beyond the shrine.
So down here.
Okay.
Just keep going.
Alright, this has to...
Wait, did I come from here?
Wait, did I...
No, no, I didn't.
Okay.
Wait, can I climb that?
Oh, I can?
Alright.
Okay, I can climb it.
Okay.
Alright.
This is it.
I figured it out.
I did not look at chat.
I figured it out with my own fucking intuition.
This is it.
I figured it out, Arlo.
With my own intuition.
Okay, how do I get up?
Okay.
Jump.
Guys, I can't climb this.
I can't.
Fucking...
Guys, who the fuck said I can climb this?
Guys, I lied.
I read chat.
And the chat fucking lied.
Chat fucking lied.
I did not get two guides.
I did not get one guide.
I get like several guides.
I fucking saw like four different people that told me to climb this.
I saw like four different people that told me to climb this.
I literally saw four different people that said you should climb it.
And I was like, oh my god, I figured it out.
Where's Arlo going?
Arlo, where are you going?
I need you to go this path.
Okay, maybe it's this way, right?
Where did I come from again?
I came from the top, so it has to be...
Wait, where did I come from?
Where did I...
Here.
I did not come from here.
Yeah.
Here.
Alright, this is where I didn't come from.
So the lake should be down there.
It should be left side, because that's where the thing is.
Right?
It should be left.
This is where the lake should be.
Oh my god, I'm so f***ing lost.
This has to be where the lake is.
Because the thing was like, go left.
Oh no, where's the GPS telling me?
No, I'm going back in the same area.
I'm going... I'm going around again.
No, where's the GPS?
Oh, go right.
Okay.
I go right.
Okay, this way.
Alright, I turned around.
Apparently the last time I went left.
Now I go right.
This is where lake is.
Lake.
How do you guys remember where the f*** the lake is?
Sleepy, I left for a meeting.
Are we still looking for the lake?
Sleepy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, now it's sand.
Why sand?
Sand eventually leads to lake.
Guys, if you guys didn't know.
Sand becomes water.
Because that's where sand comes from.
Sand comes from like...
The... the like erosion of rock.
From water.
This is where lake is.
Right?
Lake?
Where is this?
Is this the lake?
Where the f*** do I get down?
This is lake!
Oh my god, this is lake.
We made it.
I told you.
I told...
Sand eventually becomes water.
Water!
By pure science!
I f***ing knew it.
I f***ing...
I swear like...
Majority of this gameplay is just me trying to figure out where the f*** things are.
Alright.
Okay, I thought I was gonna die from that.
How much... Oh my god.
Oh f*** okay.
Okay, not jumping anymore.
I lost a lot of HP from that.
Unless...
Whoa!
That's f***ing right.
I'm gaming.
Where is he?
Panzer, thank you for the 20 ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Here we go.
Oh, he's fish!
Wait, electric fish.
Does it hurt?
I wonder if I touch...
Man, I wonder if I touch the electricity in the water.
Will it hurt?
It's time to find out.
F*** around and find out.
Please don't f*** around and find out.
Please don't.
Alright.
Here I go.
Time to touch the...
Touch the fish.
Time to touch the fish!
Sir, can I touch you?
Remember to ask permission.
Sir, I am here for the appointment.
Sir?
I am here for the appointment.
Do not worry.
I am a professional.
Sir.
It's not gonna hurt.
It's not gonna hurt when I give you your acupuncture, sir.
It's all about getting rid of that tox... the dirty toxins in your body.
How do I f***ing piss him off?
Come on, come up.
Look on the water.
What the f***?
Not like that.
Woah, woah.
Woah.
Where's the part...
Where's the part where it doesn't do that?
Oh!
What?
No, I missed out!
I'm so confused!
I missed out!
I hear you.
Don't worry, I figured it out.
I didn't know the tail...
I didn't know I was like just the f***ing...
I didn't know I was just out of reach from the tail, to be fair.
Oh my god.
I can't even get up on this.
Where does he go back up to breathe air, apparently?
Are you like a shark?
Where you need to go back up to breathe air?
Is that a...
You're not a fish.
You're a fake fish.
If you need to come back up for water, you're a f***ing fake fish.
Broko, thank you for the gift of ship.
Thank you.
You need to come back to the surface.
You ain't a f***ing real fish.
You're a f***ing lie to society.
Alright.
Where is he swimming to?
Where are you swimming to?
Where the f*** is that?
How the f*** do I get there?
Like...
Oh my god.
Bro, how the f***...
Are you serious?
Are you f***ing kidding me?
Okay.
This is it.
This has to be the tail.
Tail, tail, tail, tail.
Go up, tail.
Go up.
Nice.
That's what?
It still didn't even go up.
Yeah, I was thinking about dolphins.
I am trying my best.
He barely goes back up for water.
Ow.
Oh, oh, oh.
I did it.
I f***ing did it.
What do I do?
I'm not even on the right side of history right now.
Wait, where am I?
Like, where am I?
Where the f*** am I?
Oh, there I am.
How do I...
I'm so...
Please, please head back up.
Please.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to cry.
Oh, okay.
Here you go.
I'm okay.
Oh, no.
Grab on.
Okay.
Silly dokey.
You're always on the right side.
Okay.
We're...
We're fine.
Okay.
There we go.
Don't worry!
Oh my god!
I can feel the stress on this muscle too!
Don't worry!
Look at all the stress juice!
The more stress juice there is, the more you know I'm helping!
Oh, it's already disabled?
Bro, I didn't know that.
I was thinking... Whoa!
Let me climb up here.
Overkill Doki.
It's the stress juice!
You never heard of it?
Guys, whenever you're super stressed out and you poke deep enough, all the stress juice comes out.
Oh no.
No!
Okay.
No.
No, I'm drowning.
Wait, I'm actually drowning.
I forgot I have to breathe.
Guys, did you know humans cannot breathe underwater?
Did you guys know that?
Fun fact, we were not meant... Fun fact guys, our lungs are not built to breathe underwater.
Is that so fun?
What?
No way.
I know!
This game just taught me that.
Humans can't breathe underwater!
Science brought to you by Doki Bird.
Mama Shiba.
God, I love Mama Shiba.
I used to watch that shit.
I didn't like me... Like when I was little, I made a fucking like digital wallpaper of Mama Shiba.
And I posted it on Tumblr.
Yeah, ow.
Yeah, that was me.
Where's the tail?
Grab.
Alright.
I grabbed.
I love Mama Shiba.
It's actually one of my favorite...
One of my favorite animated shorts ever.
I learned so many fun facts.
It's how I became so fun.
That's why I'm so fun, guys.
I know all these fun facts.
I just...
Nope, I can't.
I can't let go.
I need to wait until I resurface and then I can like run.
Oh God.
Okay.
Bro, this sucks.
Bro.
I have to get closer.
Come on, just head up.
Get over there.
The Doki Special.
The Doki Special is coming!
Okay.
This has to be it.
Bro, that was like a tiny ass poke.
Alright, there we go.
Oh my God.
You gotta lay off on the electricity, man.
It's all the fucking electricity.
You're just getting more and more stressed out.
Oh, I just... Oh, I disabled the electricity.
Bro!
It's because of all the electricity causing all the stress juice to build up.
You gotta relax, bro.
It's not good for you.
Don't worry.
I have a home remedy.
Guys.
Guys, I'm 1 HP.
Guys, I don't think he likes my home remedies, guys.
I don't think...
I didn't think he liked that.
Oh, this is so bad.
I'm like 1 HP right now.
Oh.
Don't worry.
I can like heal, right?
1 HP ain't so bad.
Just don't get hit.
Of course.
Do I... Can I like heal if I was just...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Do I... Can I heal if I just like stand on somewhere?
Is it because I'm swimming that I'm not self-healing?
Alright, let's see.
I'm just gonna stand over there.
Alright.
Don't worry, sir.
I'll be right back.
Alright.
Am I self-healing?
Why the fuck are you tired?
Why are you tired?
You little bitch.
You're not allowed to be tired.
It's all about satisfying the customer's demands.
Then you can go home back to your one... back to your studio apartment.
Hahaha.
The customer is always right.
Look.
Oh, I have to crouch.
Oh, crouch to heal faster?
Oh, so smart.
Welcome to the service industry.
Bro, this is getting too real.
Hahaha.
This is the life we sign up for.
Come back up.
Come back up so I can grab your tail.
Sir, can I still grab your tail?
Sir, look at you!
I can see... Oh my god.
I can feel the stress aura from your fucking body.
From my home.
Don't worry.
You just need a crystal.
Can I recommend you a crystal for you to purchase?
Where the fuck is the tail?
Oh!
I missed.
Guys, there was the tail.
Can I recommend you some crystal healing?
Queen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doctor, you want to cancel my appointment.
Here's the refund.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Don't worry.
I can grab on the second.
No, he's just being shy.
He's just being shy because I'm like streaming my sessions.
You know those people that stream their actual job?
Like those convenience stores?
And like...
Like those convenience stores and stuff where they stream their jobs and stuff?
Sir!
I know like it wasn't in the fine print when you fucking bought my server.
But like...
There's a lot...
I have to also...
Look, I have bills to pay.
I have bills to pay.
Alright?
And I need the content.
So like...
I'm here to stream this acupuncture session.
You're violating patient confidentiality.
Look.
To violate doctor-patient confidentiality means that I actually have to be licensed.
Which I totally am.
Which I am, chat.
Which is totally true.
Alright, this has to be the tail.
Did I grab onto it?
Look, nice.
Alright, I grabbed the tail.
I firmly grasped the tail.
I totally am licensed, guys.
It's not like I learned from online YouTube videos.
But to be fair, like you know...
It doesn't hurt.
Like a person who learns from YouTube videos is just as valid as a person who learned professionally at school.
They are just the same.
This is only my...
This is like, you know, my opinion as someone who got my degree professionally.
Who licensed professionally.
But like...
I think personally, self-taught people are just...
Oh my god.
Okay, give me a second.
Like...
I personally think people who are self-taught are just as valid.
Please let me get closer.
Please.
Okay, there we go.
No!
Fuck!
Oh god!
I'll take it!
I'll take it for the content!
Phew!
There we go.
Oh, thank god.
I got the head.
Alright.
Come on, get back up!
Get back up there!
Phew!
Boop!
Nice.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Thank god I finally got to the head.
Look!
Look at that!
I got rid of all your electricity!
When you get really stressed out, like, lightning starts coming out.
Alright, here we go.
Come on, please!
Sir!
I charged you by the hour!
It looks really fucking cool.
Yeah, it does.
Alright, there you go.
Bye-bye.
Phew!
Oh god.
Come on!
Let me fucking poke you!
Yes.
You can see I've already helped him so much, you know, because he doesn't have electricity anymore.
Alright.
Phew!
Oh, I did it.
Yay!
Anyway.
Oh, I'm back.
Unrelated to this, but we're having fish for dinner.
I also made, like, a little blowhole for them so, like, they don't have to always, like, come up all the time, up in the air for, you know, to breathe.
They just need to poke their little blowhole.
Uh, I self-made a blowhole for them.
Another happy customer.
What a happy customer.
Baby fish.
So happy!
So considerate!
I know.
Unrelated to this, but... Dragoons, I got you guys fish for dinner.
Totally not dead, by the way.
Of course not!
He's not dead!
He's so relaxed that he fell asleep deep in the ocean.
That's how fishes sleep.
Guys, it didn't float up!
I got you guys!
Guys, did it float up?
No!
If it was dead, it would float up!
It did not float up!
So in the end, it is still alive.
Who's the specialist here?
Who is the licensed, not self-taught, massage parlor owner here?
Look at all my happy customers surrounding me.
If they were not happy, they would not be surrounding me with...
Surrounding me and giving me glowing reviews.
Happy is such a strong word.
Ooh, what if I don't want to look at it?
I don't want to look at God.
Nope, gonna look away.
The forest?
Ooh, the forest colossi.
Who's my next happy customer?
Where's the license?
Okay, you guys want to see my license?
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay, fine.
You guys don't believe me?
Guys, okay.
Okay, let me show you guys my... my license real quick.
Let me... let me show you guys.
Look, before we... because I have some fucking doubters right now in my chat.
So I'm here to prove you guys wrong that I have a license to be a massage parlor owner.
To like, do acupuncture.
Alright, look, it's called... you guys might not know this.
But I am licensed... to...
Sorry for speaking so slow because like today I feel extra stupid.
Like...
Hahahaha!
And then... Oh, I found... and then... Okay, so I found my photo ID too.
So...
Here it is.
And...
Uh...
Wait, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Sorry.
It's so hard to find it because it's like...
There's like so many files in my PC.
So I'm still trying to find it, you know?
I'm still... I'm still trying to find it.
So it's...
It's really hard to find it because, you know, my file... There's just so many files in there.
Uh... But don't worry.
Don't worry.
I think...
Oh, wait, wait, wait!
I found it!
Okay, I think I found it.
Okay.
Give me a sec, guys.
It exists, by the way.
It 100% exists.
I just need a...
I just need it to like, you know...
Um...
Oh, it's on the wrong file type, guys.
It's on the wrong file type.
So I need to...
Uh... I need to like convert it to the right file type.
Give me a sec, everybody.
I'm just...
I'm just converting my...
Converting it to the right file type real quick.
And then...
Alright, here we go.
Okay, and then...
Alright.
Okay, it's in like W-E-B-M-P.
I don't know why I saved it as a W-E-M-B-P.
But...
But like...
Oh my god.
You guys are gonna regret this.
You guys...
You guys are gonna regret saying I don't have a license.
You're gonna regret it.
License...
That... That... That I earned from like...
Massage school.
You're gonna regret it.
I earned this in massage school.
Okay, and then...
Give me a sec.
Guys, okay.
Found it.
I found it.
I found the I-I-D.
I found the I-I-D, chat.
Oh my god.
You're so...
I found the I-I-D, chat.
Give me a sec.
I need a... I need to pin my I-I-D onto my shirt.
So you guys will know every time when you see it that you'll know that that is a 100% real I-I-D right there.
Alright.
What the...
Look, I even scanned it.
I found my I-I-D.
And I even scanned it for you guys.
So you guys would know.
That's how dedicated I am.
I even scanned my I-I-D to my PC.
Because it was a hard copy license.
If you are a licensed massage parlor owner...
Like you would know that you have to like...
Have a physical copy of your license at all times.
There you go.
Wait, you can't really see it.
You can't really see it.
There.
There you go.
So real.
It's so real!
It's so real.
I got it at like massage school.
No, it's real!
I scanned it!
I scanned this fucking license!
How can you say this is not real?
I don't understand!
And so...
It even has a photo I-D!
So people can't impersonate me!
Like...
How can you guys say that?
Bro!
I can't believe it.
I'm gonna put this like...
This is my face now.
Where's the license- It's on the back of the card!
Everybody knows the license number is or- For those who are like, Oh, where's the license number?
We all- Real massage- Massage owners knows that the license number is on the back of the card.
You guys, you're just fucking jealous.
You didn't complete massage school.
You're jealous.
You don't have a thriving massage business like me.
What is that?
You are all fucking jealous!
That's some strong paper attorney badge energy.
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, here you go.
Now you know.
Now you guys will always know that I have a legit license to massage.
Here's my name tag right here.
I'm like certified.
That's the Canadian way of spelling license!
I'm sorry!
Why is license spelled like that?
It's the Canadian spelling of license!
It's like British English, but Canadian English.
My Canadians would vouch for me.
It's the Canadian way.
You guys don't understand because you're not Canadian.
You're not part of the...
It's like West Coast Canada too.
People are like, oh, I'm in Canada, but we don't spell it like that.
Yeah, but that's the West Coast of Canada way of spelling license.
You don't know that because you're not on the West Coast.
You're like, you must be an Eastie.
I bet you're an Eastie, man.
Yeah, I'm Canadian.
Yeah, Breeze, I bet you're an Eastie.
You're not a Westie.
It's the Canadian... It's the West Coast Canadian way of spelling license.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
You just don't understand.
You didn't grow up where I grew up.
By the way, I know it's been like an hour into the game, but I hope the volume's been okay.
I know it might be a bit too late to ask, but I hope the volume's been okay throughout it so far.
As a true maple syrup drinker, that is a proper...
Yeah, see!
I knew it!
I knew it.
Whoops, whoops.
I fucking knew I was right.
I knew it.
Shout out to Bagg.
Bro, I don't even have to click it.
Shout out to Bagg for the super chat.
The very first super chat, too.
His very first super chat on the channel.
And Vy, like, fucking endorses what I say.
As a true maple syrup drinker, that is a proper massage parlor license.
Yeah.
I knew it.
I knew I was right.
I fucking knew it.
I actually wanna raise the music just a little bit.
I'll raise it a little bit.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I was correct.
Okay, this way.
Paid actor.
He is not paid!
Alright, this way.
Where am I supposed to go?
I can't believe I'm so far west again.
I now live in Quebec.
Prezy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I bet you Quebecois!
Spoken like a true Quebecois!
Nice try, Doki, but you forgot one vital point.
Canada is not real.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's why I'm a Vtuber.
Not real.
Just like women!
I fucking knew it.
Canada and women weren't real.
I knew it all along.
Okay, I need to like fucking figure out where to go.
It has to be this way, right?
Alright.
Okay.
If you're Canadian and you are trying to say I'm not right, If you're Canadian and you are trying to say I'm not right, If you're Canadian and you are trying to say I'm not right, I bet you're Quebecois.
For those who are like, what does that mean?
That's like, sort of like the Canadian insult.
The people who disagree.
And so, here's a little Canadian history.
But like, even if Canadians disagree with each other, they can all agree that like, the Quebecois is a...
People in Quebec.
They can all agree that they do not like the people in Quebec.
And if you're from Quebec, Bro, you know it's true.
You know it's true.
Bro, okay.
Here's a little story.
I have a friend from Quebec.
And then he told me like, yo, yeah.
I was like, oh shit, where are you from, Canada?
I was like, Quebec.
And I was like, oh, Quebec.
And he was like, I know.
I'm from Quebec.
It's because like, okay, the reason why Quebec is like, um, has this reputation, is that Quebec has always tried to like, peace off from Canada.
Because like, Quebec has their own fucking, like, they're like, it's like, if like, a random state in America has their own like, party.
Has their own political party.
And like, they make like, lots of demands and stuff.
So like, Quebec has their own party called the Qubcois.
I think, I remember the, it's like the Qubcois, I forgot.
It's like, they have their own political party.
And like, at one point in Canadian history, they try to vote to be like, their own fucking, basically they try to vote to be their own country.
They try to, they try to vote to be not Canada.
And try to be like, their own like, their own like, fucking independent country in the middle of Canada.
Not once, but twice.
People are like, fucking Qubcois.
So that's why like, every Canadian can agree that like, you can be like, the goddamn Qubcois.
It's like a, it's like a little, it's a little like, running joke in Canada.
It's like a, it's like a little, This way.
Here we go.
Actually, Texas, but in Canada.
Okay, but yeah, it's a little, it's a little Quebec fun fact.
A little Canadian fun fact.
Um...
And so it's a little, it's And like, it's like, I'll just say like, you know when a Canadian is from Quebec.
It's actually funny, cause like, if it tells you anything, XQC is from Quebec.
And like, a lot, like the thing is, a lot of people from Quebec like, are very similar to like, how XQC is like.
Like...
Like, I've met so many people from Quebec that has a very similar personality to like, XQC.
And that was like, before he like, blew up.
Like before he became like, a super, a super big streamer.
And like, there were, like you know, before like, people started emulating him and stuff.
But like, a lot of people in Quebec act very similar.
Alright, yeah of course he's Canadian.
Yeah, he's from Quebec.
He's Quebecois.
Let's see...
There's a little, a little fun fact there.
Where the fuck do I go?
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That explains a lot.
Alright.
Bro, I watched this, I watched the stream speaking as a little French Canadian.
Yeah, we're a little funny.
Thanks, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, I was right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How dare you call me a Quebecois.
I'm writing my Caso Doki twitlogger right now.
The explanation works.
I just show my seriousness.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
I said it.
Now where do I go?
Where do I fucking go?
I'm so lost.
Why am I always lost?
Turn left.
My greatest enemy.
Is this this way?
It must be this way.
Am I going back here?
Okay.
It must be this way.
Right?
Oh my god.
Tell me where to go.
No!
God!
Guide me!
Oh my god.
God would tell me like how to kill.
But they won't tell me where to go.
This fucking sucks.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking use this.
Oh my god.
I get fucking launched.
Alright.
This...
It's like here.
How the fuck do I get there?
Alright, this way.
Did I pass it?
How do I pass it?
I don't know where it is.
I ran past it?
Here's some yellow for your pain.
P thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How the fuck do I pass it if I don't even know where it is?
It's like here!
It's a cave?
Oh, it's a cave.
Okay, now I need to look for the holes in the rocks.
Alright.
There has to be a hole in the rock somewhere.
Where the fuck is the hole in the rock?
Alright.
I gotta run in a circle again.
Wait, are there any fruit in this tree?
There is!
Okay.
TPS time.
That's a fruit, right?
Yeah, that has to be a fruit.
Okay.
I almost forgot how to use my fucking bow.
This is one tiny fruit.
Where the fuck did it go?
Where the fuck did the fruit go?
Hello?
Did the fucking ground absorb the fruit?
Like, excuse me?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it was a pineapple.
Yum.
Okay.
It was like camouflaged.
Alright, let's see.
Boop.
Wait, do pineapples... Pineapples don't grow on trees!
What the fu- Is that a pineapple?
What the fuck kind of fruit is this?
What kind of genetic mutations of a fruit is this?
This is not a pineapple.
Pineapples...
Oh my god, when I saw what a pineapple tree looks like, what a pineapple plant looks like, they do?
No, they don't.
They grow on the fucking ground.
You guys have never seen a fucking pineapple plant?
They're like...
It's like some... It's like... Okay, it's like a giant...
It's like a fucking grass, and then like a fucking giant pineapple in the middle.
It's so fucking weird.
I never like realized how fucking weird pineapple trees are.
Like, not pineapple trees, but like a pineapple plant.
They're like bushes, yeah.
Like, they... It's like a pineapple bush.
You'd think that pineapples come from a tree, but it's like a bush.
Look up like... Look up like a pineapple bush or something, and then you'll see what I mean.
It's so fucking weird.
It's literally like a bush.
It's not even like a real tree.
Oh yeah, selective breeding.
Oh yeah, no, we fucking did a lot of that type of shit.
I was...
I've been like getting like YouTube shorts of people selective breeding like silk moths or whatever.
And that's what they're called.
And then like...
Apparently like, we like uh, we selective breed like uh, silk moths so much that their wings don't even work.
Like...
Like, their wings...
Their wings don't even work, and that they're only... When they...
When they like, uh, come out their cocoons, all they do is wanna fuck.
And then they... Their mouths don't even work.
Their mouths are like...
Like their brain is just... They wanna bang.
So they don't eat for five days.
Like three to five days.
They don't eat for three to five days, and all they do is just bang.
And then they die.
Like they come out their cocoons.
They come out their silk cocoons, bang for three to five days.
Like bang for like three to five days, and die.
That's like their life cycle.
That's... That's all.
It's so fucked up.
They have a mouth, but they don't know how to use the mouth.
And apparently their guts are so fucked.
Their guts don't even work.
It's so messed up.
It's on the other... Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get on the other side of the cave?
Oh my god.
And then, like the lady...
The lady was like...
Was like, oh yeah, like we selectively bred the moths so much that like these moths don't... The male moths don't even know how to detach.
I was like, what do you mean they don't know how to...
I was like...
The YouTube short lady was like, yes, we selectively bred these moths so much that like the males just don't know how to detach.
So you have to intervene and like detach them yourselves.
I was like, what?
Like...
It's like...
Yes, like I have to like detach them myself or the females won't be able to lay their eggs.
Cause all the males wanna do is bang.
And I'm like bro, oh my god.
Bro, they...
I was like, what the fuck, bro?
That's so fucked up.
Oh my god.
An actual shrine.
I haven't found a shrine in forever.
Yeah.
Yeah, oh yeah.
The bushes make only one pineapple.
It's actually crazy.
Pineapple bushes only...
They only make one pineapple.
There's a giant fucking pineapple.
In the middle of a bush.
Nice prey.
They made them too.
Whoa, what the fuck?
He's right here.
That's looking nice.
He's literally right here.
Thank you for like just sitting there.
He literally was like, hey, I haven't seen a person in 20 years.
New friend.
And I'm like, yes, new friend.
Alright, let's see.
Maybe here.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Thank god for that lizard for letting me eat him.
New friend.
Time to eat him.
The survival instinct of a silkworm.
This has to be the cave.
There's no other caves.
It has to be the cave.
Alright, I'm just gonna fucking walk now.
Alright Arlo, I'm just gonna walk.
Here we go.
Time to kill you.
I mean time to rehabilitate this person.
Don't worry, sir.
Wait, where is it?
Oh man.
Sorry, my solar powered GPS doesn't work here.
Alright, we gotta run up.
Alright.
Time to fucking go.
Hey Doki, how do I know if acupuncture is right for me?
I'm tall and the back of my arms hurt.
Is that a requirement?
Skellum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry, as a professional licensed like acupuncture specialist.
Wait, give me a sec.
Let me check my solar power.
GPS needs to tell me where to go.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Um.
Thank you.
What a good question.
Alright.
So like, if you touch under your arm, and you feel all the stress juices coming out right now.
Like you feel the stress juices underneath your skin suit.
That means you're like super stressed out.
So like, all that like liquid in your arm right there, it's like, those are like the stress toxins building up.
So...
See, it's the stress toxins building up under your arm.
So like, obviously, if you want to try a home remedy...
I would highly suggest, so like, if you want to try a home remedy as a specialist.
By the way, don't try this at home.
But what I would do is that I would get like a really, like you know, like a very sharp needle, just like the sword.
You know?
Just like...
Just like the sword, you know?
And just start digging the stress toxins out.
But obviously don't do that.
Do not do that.
I am a professional!
Contact your local acupuncture artist.
Contact your local acupuncture artist to help you get that toxin out.
to help you get that toxin out.
I am a specialist, so I can do it.
Look at all the colossus that... that I have.
Uh...
They gave me glowing reviews.
Where the fuck do I go?
Is it here?
Is it inside here?
Yes, do not perform acupuncture on yourself.
Contact your local specialist.
Oh my god, my solar powered sword does not work right now.
I...
Oh my...
Oh, it's like over there.
Okay, I see it.
I see it now.
I see the tempo.
Alright, disclaimer by the way.
I need you guys to know this was just a joke.
Um...
I am a professional.
So I am legally allowed to do stuff like this.
Bro, a GPS sword that's solar powered has to be the worst fucking sword.
Has to be the worst fucking GPS device.
Cause it's like, what if it's nighttime?
What if it's nighttime and I have to kill a colossus?
How would that work?
I have it like... Where's your license?
Where's your fucking license?
Right here.
Any lawyers in chat?
I must have a lawyer dragoon right now.
Any dragoon lawyers in chat?
Here to verify my very legal license.
Where's...
Where's the notary?
I must have a notary here.
I need a notary right now.
Hahaha Papa Korn, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As an actual licensed massage therapist, I'm smiling but I'm shaking my head.
Papa Korn, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cause you're shaking your head at the chatters, right?
Cause you're like, I can't believe these people in chat does not know like basic fucking massage stuff.
Hahaha Bro, I know!
Korn, I fucking know.
I can't believe they doubt our fucking skills.
Just because you don't see massage therapy, just because you doubt my skills doesn't mean I'm wrong.
I don't think this is it.
Hahaha Oh no, there's a real one?
Yes, me!
I'm the real one!
What the fuck do you mean, oh no, there's a real one?
You've been watching a real massage therapist this entire time.
Phew.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we must go this way.
I wonder if Arlo can get here.
Arlo, can you get up here?
Arlo?
Can you get up here?
Well, how good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The significance of your certificate seems forged.
What are you, a real lawyer?
Come back when you have a law degree.
Thank you for the super chat, Momo.
Where's your fucking law degree?
Are you a notary?
That's fucking right.
Post your fucking degree right now.
But like, don't dox yourself.
Post your real degree on Twitter right now in my birdseeders tag.
But also do not dox yourself.
Make sure the censored, like, the...
I didn't think that could die.
Just so you know.
But also, I only take Ivy Leagues.
I only take Ivy Leagues degrees.
Ivy Leagues degrees.
Alright, how the fuck do I get downstairs?
Alright.
Oh yeah!
And it has to be like a... How the fuck do I get downstairs?
Oh, this way.
It has to be a Canadian...
Oh my god!
A Canadian university that is equivalent to...
I mean like...
Because American massage laws are not the same as Canadian massage parlor laws.
Checkmate.
Alright.
What are these requirements?
These are all the requirements to like...
Is he mean?
Fuck!
Okay, he's mean.
He's...
He's a mean guy.
He's not... He's not happy.
Sir, I'm ready for your appointment, sir.
Sir, don't worry.
I'm ready for our...
Sir!
Sir, I'm ready for our appointment.
Oh shit!
Oh wait!
We're still okay.
Where the fuck do I shoot?
His legs?
Sir, here's the acupuncture right now.
Oh, he didn't like that.
Oh, did I do it?
Okay.
Did I get fall damage from that?
No, I don't.
Okay.
I'm coming over, sir!
Don't worry!
Everybody likes a bro!
Okay, time to slap the dick.
Don't worry!
I am also a licensed veterinarian!
There's too many lizards out there!
We need to make sure we fix the lizard population!
Hahaha!
Guys, I am only trying to fix the lizard overpopulation as well!
I just got my veterinarian degree too, chat!
So I'm here to fix the...
I'm here to fix the...
It's like when there's too many cats and you got neutered cats.
That's what I'm doing.
It's a tough job.
But like, there's just too many cats.
Too many lizards in the world.
You saw the lizards?
You all saw how many lizards there were out there!
Hahaha!
I'm a licensed veterinarian!
I'm here to solve the overpopulation!
He's acupuncturing!
Hahaha!
And neutering services?
Um... It's neutering services?
You wouldn't understand.
The fuck?
There you go.
Does he not like it when I shoot his toes?
Where the fuck is his other toe?
There it is.
There you go.
Sir!
We have a problem!
Your late night...
Your late night fucking romps are an issue!
Sir!
Where the fuck is the...
Wait, did I stab everything?
Where the fuck...
Where?
Oh, it's cause I didn't have my sword out!
Sir!
Hahaha!
I was like, where the fuck is your dick?
Bro, I didn't know I was that good at my job.
Bro!
Hahaha!
I just thought I was really good at my job!
I thought I was really good at, like, neutering!
Hahaha!
Neutering lizards!
I don't know!
Hahaha!
I don't know, I just thought I just got it the first try!
Alright, he's gotta climb.
Gotta climb.
Get over here.
Bro, you can't just...
Yes, I can!
It's part of neutering!
Only licensed veterinarians can fact check me.
Are you a licensed... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Don't talk to me unless you're... Don't fact check me unless you're a licensed veterinarian!
That's right.
I bet you're not even a licensed veterinarian.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Okay, we gotta...
Grab the heart now.
So he can stop falling in love with all these lizards.
Hahaha!
It's good for you!
You need... You are contributing to the problem!
Oh my... Where am I?
Hahaha!
Bro!
Get out!
Guys, we gotta, like, make sure he never falls in love again too.
Oh my god!
I don't think he liked that.
Look!
Look at all these iguanas!
In, like, LA!
They are an invasive species because of you!
Hahaha!
He did not like...
That's so crazy.
I wonder why he didn't like that I neutered him.
I...
Hahaha!
That's so fucking crazy!
Yeah, I do know, like, iguanas are, like, an invasive species.
Um, was it in LA?
I don't remember.
It was, like, some fucking state where, like, iguanas became an invasive species.
And, like, there's, like, an old order now.
There's, like, a fucking state order where, like, if you see an iguana, you gotta kill it because... because there's too many iguanas!
Hahaha!
That are, like, destroying the fucking city.
Is it Florida?
Yeah.
There's, like, a state order now where, like, if you see a fucking iguana in Florida, you gotta fucking kill it because there's too many iguanas.
It's...
That's actually fucking wild.
I didn't...
And it's all because of him!
Yeah, they're, like, actually killed on sight.
Alright, sir.
This is why you contributed to the problem.
Hahaha!
Iguana population all because of this one guy.
He got... That's why we had to fucking neuter him.
Some people just eat it.
Oh my god!
It's back to the dick?
Hahaha!
What?
Bro!
The la... Oh my god!
Get me out!
The last...
He's like, no, I will never stop!
The final shot!
Hahaha!
Guys, I didn't finish my job.
There's still babies in there.
I didn't finish my job.
Alright.
This is why there's an iguana problem in Florida.
This is exactly why.
Where the fuck is he?
How do I get out of here?
Oh, should I heal?
Oh, I didn't even realize.
Give me a sec, sir.
I'm gonna heal.
Give me a sec.
They hatchet and it felt more uncomfortable, but I can't look away.
Hahaha!
He crew it back!
He had two, like, in the kid now or some shit.
Guys, sorry.
I forgot to snip one.
I need one more from the neuter service.
Don't worry.
Ka-Ka-Doki, the massage therapist and your local neuter services.
For lizards only.
I can only work on lizards though.
Nothing else.
Look at that.
Guys, I'm so talented.
Of course you would contact your local massage therapist for lizard neuter.
Alright.
One more hit.
Don't worry!
You don't need kids!
You can't afford all the fucking child services.
Not child services.
Sorry.
What is it?
You can't afford the payments.
It's the opposite of a happy ending.
Child support.
Yeah, child support.
Alright.
Nice.
It's okay.
He couldn't afford the child support anyway.
Guys.
He literally caused the Florida iguana epidemic.
We gotta get rid of him.
Just like how barbers are used to perform surgery.
She's awake!
I did it!
Look at that.
So fucking easy.
Look, I have to have multiple jobs to afford taking care of...
Oh, it was just a dream.
God damn.
Bro, I'm just...
After neutering that fucking giant lizard, I'm getting homesick for my boo.
He heard that she heard the iguana problem was over.
Please wake...
Oh my gosh, she's so dead.
Look at her fucking skin.
Yeah, that's dead.
Bro, why isn't she now like rotting away?
A fucking...
How the fuck does she look so good?
That's like dead dead skin.
And she's not trying to be a fucking goth girl.
Yup, are you dead?
Yup, dead.
I feel like... Oh, a tree is near you, girl.
It sleeps in a dry lake.
Another fucking lake?!
But now it's a dead lake?!
Are you fucking kidding?
How many lakes are there?!
Oh my god.
Not to find a dead lake.
An empty lake.
More lakes.
Alright, time to pray.
Save the prey, chat.
Save the prey.
Boop.
At least three more.
There's three more!
Three fucking lakes?!
Bro!
Three different lakes!
This is why I would never survive in like the olden times.
Alright, where do I go?
Where is the fucking dead lake?
It is...
behind me.
Okay.
This is it.
It's behind me.
Come on.
If I make you go forward, maybe you'll turn by yourself.
Okay, no.
I have to physically turn.
Turn Arlo.
Arlo, go!
Isn't a dry lake just land?
No, because fucking dry lakes has a hole.
This way.
Okay.
Go, Arlo!
Go!
Take me to the dry lake!
We'll assume that dry lakes, there's a hole.
To make the dry lake.
Okay, this is the normal lake.
Where the fuck is dry lake?
Does it go to the other side?
Is it the other side?
Oh, it is.
Okay, we got...
How do I get to the...
Okay, this way.
Alright, Arlo.
Time to get to the other side.
I guess like...
I follow this pathway.
I'll go.
Please.
Arlo, please!
Please, you're better than this.
You used to be a main character.
What the fuck happened?
Okay, do I have to turn?
No.
Okay, thank god.
Arlo can walk for me now.
A nice relaxing squirrel.
You know, I think I'm doing really well with my business.
A license...
A license, massage...
A massage parlor owner.
And a...
And a veterinarian?
Get a...
And I can do both, guys.
Ladies, ladies!
I am basically...
the dream husband material.
I can perform neuters and also give you a massage.
I can fix the iguana.
The iguana pandemic.
And also...
that's so hot.
Holy shit, Arlo.
What the fuck was that?
Bro, this is like the first time he did something actually badass.
No.
It's because they are so fucking relaxed that they never get...
they never get stressed again.
Like, you won't understand.
How the fuck do I get to the other side?
They were so fucking stressed out that they like...
How the fuck do I get to the other side though?
They were so stressed out.
That I relaxed them so much with my massage and acupuncture that like...
they just never had to come back.
I basically...
relieved them of their stress.
But stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, dokey.
The dream daddy.
I mean husband.
Okay, this way.
Okay, I need to go.
Alright.
We need to go this way, Arlo.
This has to be it.
There's like tornadoes.
There's like little mini tornadoes.
And stuff.
Oh shit, this is gonna be hard.
Oh no.
I don't like this colossi already.
Bro, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Am I in like the geysers?
Bro, what the fuck is this?
Where even is the...
Where the fuck is the colossi?
Did I missed it?
Where is he?
Yeah, the yellow stone.
Did I miss it?
Where the fuck is he?
He's like here.
He's in the cave?
Why are you all in the cave?
Get out!
Get a job!
Get out of that cave!
And get a job!
It's time!
It's time to move out!
See the sun!
I am here!
I was hired by your mom!
To tell you to get out of that cave!
The cave is safe!
But the cave feels so safe, Dokie!
What's that?
That looks like a cave turtle.
Is that rock?
Am I going the right way?
Oh no.
It says like...
The colossi is like right here.
Am I going the right way?
Go back?
Okay.
No.
Go back to the geyser!
Oh, the geyser!
Okay.
I'll go back to the geyser.
I passed it?
Where the fuck did I pass it?
I can't even tell where it is.
It says here.
Alright.
Get out.
Your mom hired... I'm your life coach too.
I got a new job.
I am now also become a life coach.
Your mom hired me to turn your life around!
Where the fuck is that guy?
Where the fuck is this giant ass turtle?
Is it here?
Is this a cave?
This is a cave.
Hey, you don't need a license to be a life coach.
You just gotta win at life.
As someone who goes to therapy daily, I am gonna get your life around.
As someone who goes to therapy daily, As someone that goes to therapy, I can help you change your life.
I can help you change your life.
Do not worry!
Where the fuck is the geyser?
I assume I have to lead him to the geyser.
And then he goes like...
Or something.
Ow.
It's fine.
I got it.
I got this Arlo.
Don't worry!
I know what I'm doing!
Get over here!
Woo!
Come on!
Get over here!
Oh, I do need Arlo?
Why the fuck do I need Arlo?
Just go over the geyser.
Right?
Whoa.
I don't like that.
Arlo, get over here.
Apparently I do need you.
Poke.
Okay.
Why do I need Arlo?
I'll find out.
Why?
Over.
Come on.
Do you like the little geyser?
Is it like a little body rub?
Like, I don't...
OHHHHHHHHH!
What the fuck do I do?
Is he...
Is he getting like a little shower?
Is he liking that?
Like...
I'm so confused.
Does he like the little fucking belly shower?
I'm like trying to figure out how to...
Oh, I gotta get closer.
Alright, here we go.
Ohh!
I see...OH!
Arlo!
Don't be a bitch, Arlo!
It's just a little fire.
I'm flying!
Don't worry, I'm gonna turn your life around!
Oh, I gotta climb that!
I gotta climb the tail!
I gotta climb the tail, right?
I got you.
No!
Get back down!
I got you.
Where else would I climb?
Nice.
No!
What?
What do I climb?
Shit!
I cannot climb the tail!
Okay, I figured it's not the tail.
It's not the tail.
Oh, I have to climb the fucking legs?
Where the fuck do I climb on the legs?
Oh, I can't shoot that.
I can't shoot that.
Arlo!
I'm your favorite owner!
Oh god.
Alright.
I did lead him to the Gaza before.
Does he have to go to the Gaza again?
Come to the Gaza.
Look at this funny Gaza.
That's what I assume I have to do.
Oh, I have to be perfectly under his shell.
Oh, okay.
Wait, is that his shell?
That is!
Oh my god, that is!
Oh my god.
How is that not climbing?
It's hitting me!
Arlo, please!
Get up!
How do I flip him over?
Help!
Oh my god, this one fucking sucks.
I hate this one so much.
Oh my god.
I'm choking.
I'm choking already.
Wait, okay.
Just stand there again.
Just make that same mistake, sir.
Bro, fucking stop!
Arlo!
Let me fucking...
Oh my god, just stand underneath the Gaza again perfectly.
Do it again for me.
Is he...
Oh, he is.
He is.
Okay.
I'm gonna jump.
No!
Oh god.
With what?
My fucking bow?
What do I hit him with?
Oh god.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
It's green!
Okay.
Poke.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Arlo!
No!
No, do it again!
Do it again, please!
Please do it!
No!
Please!
Please do it again!
Oh, thank God.
Please!
Please just get up!
Okay.
Okay, one more.
Alright, I won't choke this time, I swear.
Oh my god, I fucking did it!
Oh my god, I fucking...
...fucking...
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Go.
Go, Doki.
Go!
I am your personal life coach!
Do not worry!
I am here to coach you!
Where the fuck is it?
Where do I coach him?
Where do I...
I do!
My sword is literally up!
No!
Help
me!
This is a fucking flip!
Where is the geyser?
Oh my god!
Where the fuck is the geyser?
I don't even know where to go.
I am so lost in this.
Okay.
I understand now.
I understand.
I understand now, guys.
I figured it out, guys.
Don't be disappointed in me.
I figured it out.
It took me...
Look.
Every person I coach in life is different, okay?
So like... because of that, I have to like figure out what they want.
What they want in their lives.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
I just need them to get closer.
Get closer!
Okay, Arlo.
Please don't get close to me.
I am talking about this guy.
Get him on.
Get over here.
Walk over here!
Walk!
Bro, you can't just be lazy!
Your mom told you to go outside!
Okay.
That is on you, Arlo.
That is...
That is a hundred percent on you, Arlo.
That is not on me.
That is... not on me, man.
What the fuck?
How is he able to do that?
Oh, wait.
He gets to...
Oh, he fucking falls again.
Oh, I just need to take him to the geyser all the time.
I get it now.
I get it.
Go, go, go, go.
Go.
Go, Doki.
Okay.
Go.
How do I...
Come on.
Nice.
Keep climbing.
Keep climbing, Doki.
Keep climbing!
I am climbing!
I am doing it!
Oh my god.
Please, keep climbing.
Keep climbing.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
I am just going to hold on.
Yes!
Yeah!
What?
Holy shit.
What the fuck was that?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Please.
Please!
Holy shit!
What do I do?
I am stuck!
Oh god.
I made it.
Oh my god.
I fucking made it.
Oh!
Grip.
Where the fuck is this fucking...
Where the fuck is the acupuncture hole?
Oh, there he is.
Look.
I don't want to do this, but your mom was very specific in her instructions.
Look, you have to get out of that cave.
Bro, your mom said you've been living in that cave for 20 years.
After college.
You haven't seen the thing yet.
It's like Big Brother, but it's like a one-man show.
You have to touch grass.
Your mom is so worried.
But don't worry.
Your personal life coach is here.
And I'm here to get rid of all your worries here.
This is like a patented... patented Doki Bird special.
This is what life coaches are for.
Do not worry.
Look, you have to go outside.
Go to the gym.
And like, touch some grass, man.
Your mom is so worried.
I say, what do I do?
Let's not think about that.
When did the last time I went outside?
Let's see.
Look, I am your life coach.
My life coach handles me and not you.
That's different.
We did it.
Doki Bird life coach, vet, massage therapist, and lobotomy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you again, first name.
Yeah, I did it.
I finally... Look at him.
He's ready to go outside.
I took him to grass.
That is a job well done for the Doki Bird professional life coach.
I coached him so hard that he went outside and touched some grass.
Good for him.
He's so full of life.
And so alive.
Oh my god, and his mom carried me back to the temple.
Yay!
Another job well done.
How many more colossi's do I have left?
Or colossus do I have left?
Five, right?
Because I did...
Now you're gonna meet those colossi Arlo riding skills.
That was nine, I believe.
An isolated sand dune.
Its tracks are well hidden.
I have six left.
I did nine?
Okay.
I thought I did ten.
What did I do?
I only did four today, right?
Alright.
It's time to test out my riding skills.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm a profeci- You guys have already seen how good I am at driving a horse.
It's time.
It's time to go to the sand snakes.
Alright, pray to save.
Oh, sorry.
That's not praying.
Alright.
Back to being a massage therapist.
It was nice experimenting with different jobs.
But I feel like it's time to go back to what I'm really passionate about.
De-stressing acupuncture.
Okay, let's see...
Where it is.
It's like this way.
Okay.
Alright, Arlo.
It's time.
It's time to drive my horse over.
Alright, here we go.
This way?
This way.
Okay.
I think?
It has to be.
Is it across the ocean again?
My true passion.
Being a very licensed massage parlor owner.
That is my only passion, apparently.
Which I 100% agree with.
How the fuck do I get to the other side?
I think I need to...
Oh, I need to cross the bridge.
Sir.
Okay, I need to cross the bridge to the other side.
I need to cross it here.
Right?
Can I cross it that way?
Did I go the wrong way?
Do I cross it here this way?
I guess?
Let's see.
I'm gonna cross this area.
Here?
And then I go all the way over there?
Where the fuck is this?
Okay, I guess I go here?
And then I go left, I think.
Alright.
We're gonna go to the other side now.
Don't worry.
This is the furthest appointment I'll have to go.
But don't worry, Colossus.
I am a licensed professional and I'll be here to cure all your stress.
Stupid snake.
Why are you in the sand?
Alright.
I think it's this way, right?
Where does my sword GPS tell me?
I need to call my client and tell them that I might be a little late.
My sword GPS is a little faulty.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, my God.
See?
Look at that.
Look at the way I drive my horse.
Fucking professional horse driver!
Woooo!
Oh, hello birdie!
Where the fuck is the sand?
Where is the...
Where's the sand?
This is not the sand.
Am I going the right way?
I am.
This is the only way to go.
Right?
Yeah, cause that's the ocean.
So the sand has to be nearby.
Cause when there's an ocean, there's sand.
It's on a cave?
I have to fucking...
Go downstairs?
No way.
There's no way.
Is Nidoki a horse girl?
I'm actually not a horse girl.
I never got to be a horse girl.
So now, because I never got to be a horse girl...
I can...
I can live through it now.
Cause I never got a chance to.
I get to see what it was like to be a horse girl.
Alright.
Let's see.
I don't think it's here.
Is it not?
Where the fuck is the desert?
Why does it keep pointing down?
Oh, it's cause I keep looking down!
I was like, what is this?
Okay, that makes a lot more sense.
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
Guys, I figured it out.
If you look down...
The sword... the... the...
The sword GPS...
Fucking...
Takes me downstairs.
So I just need to not look down.
Oh, hey.
Maybe I can grab some HP.
Have I grabbed HP from you?
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna fucking die.
I thought Arlo was gonna send me down to the cliffs.
Okay, did I chew the fruit from here before?
No, oh I didn't.
Alright.
Okay, whoops.
That was the camera.
Alright.
Boop!
That has to be one of the fruits.
Eat.
Nice.
Yeah, I don't have a lot of stamina.
I haven't been finding shrines.
There's another one.
Get away, Arlo.
Alright.
Where the fuck did the fruits drop to?
Hello?
Oh, here.
Yay!
And...
Fruit!
Nice.
Alright, time to figure out where the desert is.
Okay, time to go to Snake Boy.
The fuck?
Oh, nope.
GPS sword, where do you- oh, sorry.
Not in the sun.
GPS sword!
Tell me where to go!
Alright, GPS sword has spoken.
Alright, Arlo.
Arlo.
Get over here.
Look, I'm a good owner.
Alright, Arlo.
Apparently I need you to help me with the snake.
It's always a cave?
Why are they always all in caves?
What happened to them?
Why is it always a cave?
This has to be sound, right?
Is this it?
What?
No, that's not sand.
That's normal grass.
No one tell... Oh!
Oh!
Shrine!
Wait, have I been to the shrine before?
No, I haven't.
This is new.
Oh god, okay.
Alright, Arlo.
Oh, there it is!
There's a cave!
There's a sand cave!
I knew my GPS sword will take me to the right place.
Okay, time to pray.
Wait, this is not... Wait, what?
Okay, I was like, wait a minute.
Time to pray.
Alright, where the fuck is the gecko?
Now that I've fixed the iguana problem...
This should be... Oh, there he is.
Arlo, please.
Okay.
Is he dead dead?
No.
Now he is.
Alright.
You always gotta double tap.
What the fuck?
You're alive?
Oh, it's okay.
He can regrow the tail!
I let him live on purpose, cause I found out.
You can regrow the tail.
You come back to the shrine.
And then like, the tail will grow back.
Real.
Just from the Doki Bird exclusive.
You guys might not know that.
It's like a hidden Easter egg.
The tail will regrow, so you have to...
The thing is, you have to like, shoot it at the tail.
At the right part of the tail.
So like...
Mostly people, when they shoot it, they kill the lizard.
But like, if you're as skilled as me, you can shoot at the tail.
That only the tail comes off.
And not the lizard.
The lizard doesn't die.
So like, I know like a lot of people might not be as skillful at shooting as me.
But like...
But here's a little pro tip.
It's a one frame trick.
That I mastered.
Also, you have to shoot at the right angle.
So like, you come back to the shrine.
And then the lizard will have...
It's how you can farm unlimited stamina.
Alright, how the fuck do I kill this snake?
Do I just ride around and then just jump on the back?
Oh god.
He seems very angry.
Do not worry.
Oh my god.
It's the anger stress.
You know when you're so stressed out, you're just angry?
That's just him.
Don't worry.
That's why he...
That's why I got hired in the first place!
My word of mouth!
My word of mouth is working!
I don't need to waste money advertising and getting YouTube ads.
My happy clients are advertising about my great...
My great...
My great work ethics.
How do I fucking kill him?
Don't step on the snake?
But what if I want to step on the snake?
What the fuck?
Oh!
Wait, I'm getting sucked in!
Come on, I get it.
I get it.
Okay.
I get it now.
I was getting sucked in.
I was losing HP!
I just realized I was losing HP!
I was like, whoa!
I definitely did not fucking have that low HP when I started.
I couldn't tell!
I couldn't tell, guys!
Is he...
Whoa!
Bro, he's a crocodile!
It's a crocodile snake!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Do I have to shoot the eye?
Are you fucking... How do I...
Oh my god!
I figured it out!
I have to shoot the eye.
I figured it out.
Oh my god.
Can... Does he... He's gonna run into the wall.
Okay, I thought Arlo can like...
figure this out himself.
I like looked back and I saw eyes.
I was like...
I have to shoot the eye.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
As we all know...
The...
Okay, this... You guys might not...
Actually, you guys actually might not know this because you're not into acupuncture.
But like, the most risky...
Alright.
The most expensive acupuncture job is...
Are you serious?
Did he fucking hit the rock?
Come on.
The most expensive acupuncture job out there is the eye of acupuncture.
Like, you gotta be super...
You gotta be like super fucking prist...
You gotta be like super precise with this.
But do not worry.
I am a professional.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Where do you eye?
There we go.
Eye acupuncture.
Do not worry.
Okay.
Oh, I found it instantly.
Yes.
For when you shoot the eye, you reveal the...
All the stress points.
Yeah, that guy has some fucking...
Fucking...
That's when you know.
Like, that eye, you know he needed eye acupuncture.
Right there.
I basically relieved all the eye stress from him.
Oh shit, he fucking buried me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Arlo.
We gotta get the other eye.
Oh my god.
I need a fucking eye.
Arlo, don't worry.
Don't worry, Arlo.
I am a professional.
Okay.
He has to go this way, right?
Yeah.
He has to follow me from behind.
What the fuck?
Now he can jump.
That's when you know he liked it.
It's okay.
It's because he's been looking at the PC.
When you look at the PC for too long for a lot...
For...
When you look at the PC for too long for like majority of your life, you gotta get eye acupuncture.
But like you have to get it with a real professional like me.
So if you have...
If you see this license from any specialist, that's what...
That like...
My particular license.
States that like I am allowed to perform eye acu- Acu-puncture.
Where the fuck is he so slow?
Show up!
Only one.
One.
Arlo, what are you doing?
Shit, that was so scary.
What the fuck!
Okay!
Oh my god, that was so fucking scary, man.
Arlo, Arlo, Arlo, Arlo, I don't like that.
I don't like that, Arlo.
Where the fuck is the eye?
Open your eye!
Bro, only one out of five specialists?
Oh, wait.
He's tired?
Why is he tired?
Only one out of five specialists can perform this.
Oh!
I get tired from fucking drawing my bow.
I didn't even realize that.
I'm so fucking weak.
Oh shit.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
No, no!
Oh, that hurt!
Did I hit him?
I did, right?
Did I hit him?!
Oh, I did.
Okay, thank god.
I couldn't tell.
I actually couldn't tell.
Oh my god, I couldn't tell.
Get off.
Get off the horse.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Where the fuck is your...
Where the fuck is your stress?
Stress!
Where are you stress my boy?
Okay, I found the stress point.
Bam!
Don't worry!
Five clients recommend me!
The fifth one forgot to leave a review.
There we go.
We did it!
The fifth one just forgot to leave the review.
We cured stress!
Call me for an eye acupuncture.
One out of five specialists and I'm the cheapest one.
Not because I'm bad at it.
It's because I know being a specialist is like...
I know we're really in demand.
And because I care about the people.
I'm the people.
I care about the people so I make sure I'm super affordable.
For those who need it.
I need eye acupuncture.
That's why it's like I'm like the cheapest out of all four or five of them.
I do it for the people.
Yeah, I gotta make it like financially available.
It's like... it's like... what is it?
Insulin.
It's like insulin.
I'm like that guy that tried to make insulin cheaper.
That's me.
I wouldn't like let big pharma take advantage of you.
Yay!
I did it.
What does God want me to do now?
Who's the next one?
Galerian set loose.
It keeps the...
Oh wait, fire.
This is a fire guardian.
The fire colossus.
Is this another lake?
Oh my God.
You know what?
I think this is the perfect time to call it.
We'll do...
We'll do the last...
The last six on another stream.
I don't want...
I don't want to find another lake.
Let's pray right now.
Let's pray.
Pray time.
Yay!
I think we made a lot of good progress.
Chat.
We made so much progress today.
Guys.
We made so much progress.
Yeah.
Alright, let me...
Let me swap screens.
Yay!
Oh my God.
I did it.
There you go.
Did I pray?
I'm going to pray again just in case.
That was really fun though.
This game has been like super enjoyable so far.
I'm really glad I actually got a chance...
I actually get the chance to keep playing Shadow Colossus because it's been like super fun so far and definitely like...
I really enjoyed playing it for the very first time.
But I'm going to do something about super chat reading.
We haven't done those in so long because I've always been so busy and I still am very busy.
But I figured today's the day.
Today's the day we do super chat reading.
Let me find the text that pops up and be like doing super chat reading right now.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh my God.
It's been so long that I can't even find like the little text that tells people I'm doing super chat reading.
Oh, there it is.
I just didn't color code it.
Alright.
Colors.
Donation reading time!
Yeah!
I had a really fun.
It's been like...
We're going to finish this.
We're going to finish Shadow Colossus.
I'm going to finish Shadow Colossus next week guys.
Don't worry.
Next week we're going to 100% finish it.
I just figured like I didn't want to do like a super long stream.
Like I don't want to force myself to do all the Colossus today.
So I purposely wanted to leave it the all the rest for last stream because I don't know how long it's going to take me.
I don't know how long the last six Colossus are going to take me.
So I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna leave it to the last stream just in case.
Just in case I get fucked up.
Let's see.
It's been a while.
I almost forgot how to do a Super Chat reading.
Pull it up real fast.
Alright, where was I?
Let's see.
Uh...
Medi!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
Horse Girl Streams!
Woo!
Ginger!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
Not so deadpua!
Please, Dokie.
I don't want to see the stamina bar.
It distracts me!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
Look.
I am so nice.
I'm so nice I actually showed you guys the stamina bar.
I usually never do that.
You guys have to remember.
This is like a once in a lifetime.
opportunity.
Let's see.
Kaz!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
The art contest for your gamer sub started at 5th, right?
Did you have any specific details for the artist entering?
Alright, so there's been a delay.
Since there's been no details regarding the art contest.
Because we're working on the graphic right now for the art contest.
There was like some delay because we're like finalizing the rules and everything.
But so don't worry because I didn't post anything.
It just means like the official contest isn't out yet.
But the moment I get the graphics for the to post it.
That's when like, you know, boom, we start.
So.
So that's just like that's just basically it.
The reason why they're like, you know, I know we said 5th, but there's been delays and stuff.
There's just a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes every day.
I've been like super duper busy because there's been so many things that delay like not delayed.
But like there's just been a lot of things that's just being worked on.
Like it takes longer to process and stuff like that.
And oh, good news.
I started work on an original song.
Yeah.
I started working on an original song.
I started work on an original song today.
So that's like some some good news to look forward.
I don't know when when when it's going to be.
But I'm starting work on an original song with a with one of my favorite composers.
So I'm super looking forward to it.
Yeah, that's something to look forward to.
I don't know.
Look, a lot of these take a lot of time, though.
Oh my God.
Wait.
I really want to like.
I really want to spoil you guys on something really fucking dumb.
I'm planning.
But I can't.
It's so stupid.
Yesterday I received something and like yesterday I received something and it was so fucking.
I commissioned this and it's so fucking dumb.
I really wish I could show it to you guys.
But I can't.
I have to like I'm trying not to.
But wait.
One day you'll know.
One day whenever I finish setting everything up for the really dumb thing I commissioned and like I can finally show you guys.
You'll know why I was like, it's so dumb.
You'll know why when I said it was so dumb, but like it was so worth it.
One day it'll be like a serious special stream.
Chris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Atsudouki I'm excited for the end of the saga you haven't said it yet, where do we commission you for tomorrow's icon drawing stream?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, regarding the icon stuff.
We actually made a Google form, one of the mods and I, well, one of them mods shout out to one of the silent mod for making a Google for him where you can submit, like, like you like a receipt, obviously, like we'll have like a template and everything for you guys to look at the Google form.
We'll have like a template and everything for you guys to look at the Google form,
The members post will have all the details.
I'll be making it tonight.
After the stream, after I like, you know, get dinner and everything, I'll be making the...
I'll be... yeah, we know the dates.
We know what the dates of the stream is.
We'll have all the details for everybody.
On the... if you're a member, we'll have all the details in the community post.
So you guys don't have to be like, I don't know how to do this.
Like, so do not worry.
We'll give you guys the details...
of how to find the receipt and everything.
Because it should be in your YouTube.
It should be in the email associated to your YouTube.
Or like... it could be in like your Super Chat.
So don't worry.
You'll see it in the community post.
When we... when we like, organize everything.
When I post a community post.
Many!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Also, GamerSubs creator code.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god!
I didn't know being a GamerSubs partner, we get like free...
Like...
like...
Okay, I know we get like free stuff sometimes.
But like...
I received an email today.
That was like, you have made an order.
To like... GamerSubs.
And I was like, huh?
I...
I was like, what?!
Obviously I can't read what the order is.
Because I think they're like flavors.
In like cups.
That haven't been released yet.
Because I was like looking at it.
I was like, what the...
I was like, I didn't make an order.
I was so confused because I was like, I didn't make an order.
What is this?
And I looked at it and I was like, wait, what are these flavors?
I think like when you're a gamer sub partner, they give you like the newest flavors that come out or something.
Or the newest waifu cups that you like test it out and stuff.
Obviously, I'm not going to say what the flavor was because I'm pretty sure it's not even out in public.
I'm pretty sure it's not out in public because I looked at it and I was like, what flavor is this?
And I like Googled it and it didn't exist.
I was like, oh, oh shit.
Okay.
It's like, yeah, like I'm beta testing it or something.
Because I was like, I didn't order anything.
What the fuck is this?
So yeah, I was just like, wait a minute.
Oh my God, that doesn't even exist.
I'm pretty sure like when you're a gamer sub partner, they just send you like free samples of like the flavors themselves.
So you can test it out and stuff.
Well, I haven't received it yet.
I just literally got it.
I literally like got the email today.
Links, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Glad I made it in time.
Saw the total solar eclipse today.
It was a surreal experience.
I was sleeping.
Yay.
Also like, isn't there like another one in October or August?
I was like, I saw like people were like, oh my God, the solar eclipse.
And I was like, solar eclipse.
And I like looked it up.
There's another one coming in like August and October.
There's one every year.
So I was like, wait, what is...
Oh, in 90 years?
Wait, what?
Oh, I was also sleeping.
It didn't even show up in my area.
Oh, in 90 years?
Oh, I was like, wait, I thought eclipse happened every year.
I was like, what makes this one so special?
I was so confused.
Oh, not for another 20 years in NA.
Oh, I see.
I see.
So like people in NA are just...
We're just...
We just don't have the privilege.
I see.
I guess West Coast just...
Fuck West Coast, I guess.
All right.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fortnite retail therapy is back.
Hell yeah, it is.
Many, Foxy and Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Joe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I want to be a petition for the devil to bless Doki bow.
I don't understand.
If they can bless the sword, why can't they bless the bow too?
Like, what you have limited blessing power?
You're literally God.
Like, oh I ran out of energy to bless you now.
Like, what the fuck is that?
You might as well just fucking bless both.
If you really wanted me to do your fucking job, God, just fucking give me the power to do the job.
Like, he gets tired.
Like, oh, yeah, but he's not tired of backseating me.
No, no, no!
God is not tired of that!
Um...
Uh... let's see.
Uh...
Lolly, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Only a hundred years since toilet paper can be legally advertised.
That's splinter-free.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wes, great job.
Professional stress oil therapist.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Chi!
Speaking of solar power, did you ever play that old Nintendo Game Boy game that required to physically be under the sun?
IRL.
Thank you for the superchat, Chi.
Thank you, thank you.
No, most of the Game Boy games I played were, like, Pokemon.
And I remember I played the Pokemon one, the Dragon Ball Z game.
Where, um, it was like an RPG-esque one.
And then...
I railed!
But, like, actually a lot of the Pokemon...
Like, a lot of the Game Boy games I had were, um...
I'm trying to remember.
I literally only remember the most of the games I remember, which is Pokemon.
But like, you know, like when you're like, I don't know if this is like, an Asian kid thing or, like, any kid thing.
But, like, my mom would buy me these little, like, boxes.
And I just chuck my game cartridges in there.
Like, I just have these little...
I think they're, like, Ikea boxes.
This is the second one.
I didn't play that fucking Dragon Ball Z game for so fucking long.
So it's like embedded into my memory.
Any RPG, the RPG one, it was like semi-RPG I remember.
I don't know, I need to like look it up.
I can't remember on top of my head what it was.
But I found out that like a lot of the Game Boy games, like a lot of the Game Boy games, like Game Boy Advance or whatever, or just normal Game Boy.
Like the cartridges, like it has a battery in there and it can expire.
I didn't realize that.
I thought like, you know, it's like a CD.
It never dies, except like, I don't know, if it's like super scratched up or stuff.
But I didn't realize like a lot of them have like a little battery built in.
So like a lot of the old games are like the same.
Yeah, for the save file.
Like a lot of the old games and stuff, they don't really work anymore because there's no... the battery just dies.
The save games and stuff.
Yeah, it can die down.
So they expire.
Yeah, I didn't realize that.
So you might lose your save soon in a couple of years.
Or replace the battery.
They can recharge.
Oh, or you have to replace them and recharge it.
I thought it was super interesting.
That like, I didn't realize there were like batteries inside the cartridges.
Let's see.
Where was I?
Attack Arcade Boomer Ginger.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sleep.
Holly fuck.
Oh, yeah, this one guy was like, holy fuck.
I left out my meeting.
Are we still looking?
That was when I had the Great Lake Adventure.
The Great fucking Lake Adventure.
We made it though.
We fucking made it.
It was like a one super chat that I really wanted to read that I missed out.
I can't... God, where is it?
Where is it?
It was this one super chat I really, really wanted to read, but I can't.
It was a long one.
I can't find it anymore.
I saw it, but it went by so fast because I forgot to pull up the super...
like only super chat chat that I missed out.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is...
Does anyone remember the guy's name?
He said he had to do like go somewhere.
What was that guy's name?
What color was it?
I don't remember.
Because I remember everybody was like... was like saying something about it.
No, I don't know.
Guys, your memory is just as bad as mine.
Was it Def... yeah!
Defwisher!
That's the guy!
So everybody was like... like Defwisher.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Who's Def are you wishing for?
Like I was so confused.
I was like... because I saw the super chat like so fast.
I didn't see the name and then everybody was like wishing Def for something.
And I was like, bro, what the fuck happened in my chat?
Who the fucking... who's Def do you guys want to wish for?
I was so confused.
Oh, there you go.
Hey Doki.
I love watching your streams and admire you.
Thank you for pushing forward even when it is incredibly tough.
Couldn't do any of my maps to join the Air Force and just finished my ASVAB.
What the fuck is ASVAB?
Wish me luck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck is that?
The Armed Service Vocational Aptitude Battery.
Do you make that... what is that?
What is that apt for?
Develop abilities and help predict future academic and occupational success in the military.
Oh!
The fucking Air Force.
You have to have like...
You have to be able to like...
Like take in like... what is it?
The high pressure rates.
Like when you're flying the plane really high.
You like don't pass out and stuff.
Oh, it's an IQ test?
What's your IQ?
Hahaha.
Oh, so you're smart enough to be in the Air Force.
Can you... is that good?
I don't know.
I don't know how smart you have to be in the Air Force.
I guess you need to know physics, right?
Hahaha.
Not all of the Air Force fly planes though.
Then why they call the Air Force?
Like... what's the point?
Hahaha.
Then what?
Ground Force?
You might as well be the fucking Land Force.
If you're not all of them are gonna fly.
Yes, I don't know.
I don't know if the Air Force requires you to be smart.
I don't know.
Hahaha.
I... how is that... I'm not in the military.
Why would I know this information?
Like...
Hahaha.
I like how you guys assume I know how smart you have to be in the Air Force.
And this is the American Air Force.
I assume.
Yeah, it's in the USD.
Like, I'm not American.
How am I supposed to know how smart you have to be in America?
In America!
In American Air Force!
I barely know how smart you have to be in the Canadian...
Do we have an army?
Or like, hypothetical Canadian army?
Hahaha.
Where the majority of us are just the Mounties?
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good luck, Deafwisher, if you're still here.
You'll have a lot of fun.
I wish I joined the Air Force instead.
Motherfucker, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maddie, you have to be smart for that.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I think the f- Okay.
I don't know.
Okay.
This might be a little like, whoa, Doki!
But like, I think it's funny that the army in America has started to recruit in anime conventions.
I don't know.
And then they get like cosplay- Like, they hire like professional cosplayers to stand next to their booth to like, uh...
Like, you know.
To stand next to their booth to recruit.
I don't know.
I just find that fucking hilarious.
Like, they're trying to recruit like, we...
Like, they're trying to recruit weeds to the army now.
And I find that so fucking funny.
You guys know that?
Yeah!
They do.
That's the thing for...
I didn't realize.
No, but like, I didn't notice that until...
Um...
Until they started hiring professional cosplayers.
To like, man the booths.
Like, really like, beautiful anime girls.
Like, standing next to the booth.
So like, to like, try and sign up some like...
Some like, I don't know, some weaves to join the army.
And I thought it was like, pretty funny.
Did you know like, the US army has a Twitch channel too?
Like, they're so...
They're like, they're targeting everybody.
They're also targeting gamers.
Gamers are also not safe.
Gamers like, Twitch has an...
Like, they have an official partner Twitch channel.
And where they host like, tournaments and stuff.
And like, they like, stream...
Like, stream on Twitch.
Like, the arm...
Like, the soldiers in the US army.
Like, the members in the US army.
They actually do like, Twitch streams.
And try to host like, tournaments.
Cause they once hosted Overwatch tournament.
I remember back then, the US army sponsored an Overwatch tournament.
Like, an Overwatch Invitational.
And I remembered it.
Because like, one of my...
Like, one of the teams I was in was like, Oh my god, we should...
We should like, you know, sign up for the US Army Invitational.
Yeah, they have official teams.
They have actual official like, FPS teams too.
It is actually...
It is crazy.
They have a Liquipedia.
They sponsor like, actual like, teams in esports.
Spirit, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
As someone who is in the Royal Canadian Navy, I can say we do have an army.
One good thing about our military is that we have better training than most other...
...militaries.
Or so they say.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Name them.
Better than who?
Call them out.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Umm...
Anyway.
I am gonna call it here, everybody.
I know this was a super short superchat reading.
But then I got like, a message of some work stuff I have to do.
So I have to call it here, guys.
I had a little fun.
Zach is done with all of you guys.
I hope like, when things started stabilizing...
...we can have longer superchat talks again.
After the stream.
So...
I will try my best to stabilize as fast as...
Like, not as fast, but like...
I will try my best to one day be stabilized.
So...
I don't have to worry about work stuff after stream.
Umm...
I guess...
We are slowly getting back into it, though.
We are slowly getting back to having like, regular superchat talks.
Superchat readings after streams.
Just takes a little bit.
Slow and steady.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me...
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I will see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!
3 2